el acuerdo suspende el techo de la deuda
lo que otorga al departamento del tesoro
la autoridad de endeudamiento sin
restricciones hasta enero del 2025 antes
de que otro aumento del techo de la
deuda tenga que renegociarse esta vez
considerada una victoria para los
demócratas especialmente Paraguay quien
no tendrá que enfrentar otra batalla por
el límite de la deuda antes de buscar su
reelección en el 2024 el aumento pone
límites a lo que se conoce como gasto
discrecional el dinero que el congreso
asigna cada año para financiar agencias
y programas federales sin embargo las
restricciones no se aplican a programas
obligatorios como Medicare y el seguro
social en cuanto a gastos de defensa
este aumentará el próximo año un tres
coma tres por ciento como pidió alguien
en su proyecto de presupuesto Pero esto
está por debajo de la tasa de inflación
y no cumple con las expectativas de los
republicanos hay que mencionar que
muchos programas federales se
enfrentarán recortos recortes
presupuestarios en el próximo año ya que
no van a compensar con la inflación que
vio Estados Unidos por otro lado el
acuerdo exige una expansión gradual de
los requisitos para aplicar a los
beneficios de asistencia nutricional o
subsidios de alimentación entre otros
presidente de la cámara de
representantes Kevin mccarthy dijo que
la cámara votará este miércoles el
acuerdo dando tiempo así es suficiente
el senado de mayoría demócrata Para
probarlo antes del cinco de junio fecha
en la que Janet yelen Secretario del
tesoro dijo que era la fecha límite
antes de que Estados Unidos entrara en